[Music]
my next guest is a comedian who can be
seen at cobb's comedy club in san
francisco next wednesday and headlining
comics at foxwoods on labor day weekend
please welcome the very funny andy
haynes
[Music]
hi there thank you
uh i kind of had a rough year you guys
i'm uh i'm pretty broke
which
is hard to believe because i look like a
senator's nephew
take that in for a second i know i'm
broke because i was sleeping on an air
mattress this year
which is a broke thing that is a canary
in the coal mine for your financial
status
mattress sounds like it's going to be a
good thing it sounds like you're going
to sleep on a cloud instead what you
have is a very fragile mattress
that you can't just get into you have to
get like low and flat
and then extend or you will puncture
your bed and then not have a bed at all
you will be bedless which is worse
i want to make a commercial for the air
mattress it'll be just like the
tempur-pedic commercial like the lady's
like jumping on the bed and her merlot
is just
fine but in this commercial the lady
will jump on the air mattress the wine
will shoot up and kill her
they'll say air mattress you should have
picked a better major in college
that's a bad idea
i'm getting older uh everybody should be
getting older if you're not you should
go see a doctor
you have benjamin button disease
but you knew that you were born as an
elderly baby so
nothing new
i know i'm getting older because the
gangster rappers that i grew up
listening to
are now dying from non-gangster things
kings are supposed to die from bullets
not diabetes and cholesterol
that's not gangster
i hear about a gangster up or dying oh
i'm like what happened was it a drive-by
somebody's like nah thyroid disorder
like i wish she would have got shot
i wish she could have kept it real
if i was a gangster rapper and i knew i
was gonna die like a doctor told me uh i
would get my um posse together and i'd
be like hey could you guys shoot me in a
couple weeks
but then you'd have some really weird
news stories it'd be like today in long
beach 87 year old rapper snoop dogg
was gunned down in front of a vitamin
world
my four other 87 year olds
speaking of drizzle i'm from seattle
that's the best segue you're ever going
to hear um
seattle it rains there all the time and
just rains like 300 days a year people
come up to me they'll be like andy
you're from seattle isn't that where
everybody kills themselves
and i'm like yeah
i'm a survivor
a lot of mornings i'd wake up and i'd
see that gray and i'd be like i'm gonna
do it today
and then i remember i have a rain jacket
and i just kind of go on with the rest
of my day
it's just rain
[Music]
i uh i like uh magic mushrooms that's uh
that's something i like a lot
you guys maybe are confused about that
but it's exactly what you think it is
i like magic mushrooms they're my
favorite drug and they're my favorite
drug because they're the only drug you
can abuse
because the second you're done doing
magic mushrooms you are not trying to do
any more magic mushrooms
you're more like thank god we made it
back from that one brain
that was a close call when that tree
started to yell at us
i thought we were goners
that we might have wasted that
bachelor's degree
i made a mistake i i moved from seattle
to new york i was living there the last
couple years and i made a huge mistake i
uh i brought my girlfriend
from seattle to new york and i don't
know if you guys knew this new york
already has girlfriends i don't know if
you guys knew that
it's the place is teeming with
girlfriends like to the brim girlfriends
you don't need to bring a girlfriend to
new york
bringing a girlfriend to new york is
like bringing a warm beer
to a bar that serves free cold beers
and everybody's sitting there just
spilling cold beer all over the place
and you have to pretend that you love
warm beer
[Applause]
thanks
i brought my own
i wish there would have been a bouncer
at the door to new york
that was like hey you can't bring that
in here
there's tons of girlfriends inside
this is uh this is a fun little joke you
guys can play whether you're religious
or not it's up to you
but um the next time that somebody comes
up to you and they tell you that jesus
died for your sins go like
this what
he dies
i was reading that book man
you gotta say spoiler alert or something
thank you guys very much
that's funny
that's great yeah nice job
[Applause]